Chris scker former FBI assistant
director Paul Morrow attorney and former
head of Intel operations at NYPD Chris
now authorities say they reportedly want
to take him
alive uh how difficult is that going to
be uh given what looks like his
planning and his mental state that
authorities were aware of uh there's a
lot about this case that is extremely
disturbing in the
runup yeah Laura it's a highly lethal
combination that mental illness a
well-trained uh military uh uh from the
Army uh he he's a Firearms instructor
he's desperate he's already killed uh in
a mass shooting innocent people who
probably just froze you know there a lot
more uh in most cases you'll see more
wounded than you will killed in this
case it's the reverse so he knows what
he's doing he's not going to be taken
alive well Paul as we noted the suspect
has this uh long list of mental issues
including hearing voices uh he allegedly
made threats to shoot up the National
Guard base in Maine uh and according to
the AP he was committed to a mental
health facility in July after acting
very erratically while he was at West
Point where he was training Cadets one
of his unit mates described him as one
of the best Riflemen that that in the
entire unit so this is again a former
head of uh
NYPD how did we not have any of these
red flags sooner to stop this
massacre well there were a lot of red
flags just to be clear Maine has what's
known as a yellow flag law and under the
yellow flag laws the only people that
can refer somebody like uh uh this guy
to a uh civil court in order to overcome
the Second Amendment and take his
Firearms away away from him are law
enforcement red flag laws family members
can do it other people who are
positioned to see that he's sliding off
the deep end and get the guns away from
him it's a uh you need due process and
it's not an simple process New York has
this procedure Maine however had what
was believed to be maybe the model for
the future in a lot of States because it
was only going to be law enforcement as
in the police or prosecutors now it is
coming to light that maybe he did have a
Brushwood law enforcement relative to
this mental health uh issue that he had
in the two we stay in July in a mental
health facility these are questions that
people are going to be looking back on
but the most important thing now is to
try to get this guy and as Chris said
there's a lethal combination between the
training he has not only militarily but
his outdoor training you know he's an
Outdoorsman and he knows the terrain up
there he's well equipped you can see he
was wearing combat gear his pockets were
bulging with likely extra magazines this
guy is not going to go easily and uh the
Tas Force up there has their work cut
out for them now Chris given the fact
that we know he was uh involved in
advanced planning for these horrific
murders that took place and also hiding
places how dangerous is it for the
authori searching for him I mean someone
like him if he's hearing voices you
could see he would turn himself into a
sniper against the police and other law
enforcement in search of
him yeah well first of all you know they
found the car uh by the dock by the
river he either jumped into a switch car
and he's hundreds and hundreds of miles
away or he went into the woods and I
think it's highly likely he went into
the woods and law enforcement's going to
have to go in and get him they're going
to have to set up a large perimeter
which they already have and of course
they got aerial assets but like Eric
Rudolph the Olympic bomber he knows the
area better than the authorities he
hunts in that area it's likely he
prepositioned hideouts throughout the
area with with ammunition as well
supplies and they're going to law
enforcement's going to have to go in and
get him and as you say he had the
advantage Eric Rudolph later said he
would hide in the woods and law
enforcement would come within 10 15
yards of him never saw him so he could
pick officers off if they're not careful
it's going to have to be a tactical
operation over a huge area and it may
take a long time which means resource
eventually start melting away so I I
think he again I think he's in the woods
somewhere I people go like this go where
they're familiar and we don't he I don't
see him Meandering around the country in
a car now Paul do you agree with that I
assume you know they have uh dogs uh on
premises they're drawing down at the
various locations where they know he has
affiliations with uh certain properties
um tell us what that means so you know
there's this reporting that some Flash
bangs were heard you use the flashbangs
to do Dynamic entries generally for a
couple of reasons number one if you
think you might be walking into some
booby traps so they might have been
concerned about that you also do it to
flush out the suspect another reason is
to stun any animals usually a dog uh it
doesn't hurt the dog the idea is to do
this humanely the dog is stunned and
then you can Corral him in a humane way
so they are hitting his locations
apparently the family has number of
properties they want to make sure he's
not in there my understanding is that
they're drawing down from there up in
Maine right now so it looks like that
might have been an empty well so I think
uh I I would have to agree if we had to
make a call right now I think he's going
to go to what's familiar we know he's an
Outdoorsman we know it'd become
increasingly paranoid the reporting is
that he's been losing his hearing and
that he's been hearing these voices more
or less at the same time contemporaneous
with losing his hearing and some of the
the reporting now that's coming out is
that the voices he was hearing he was
contending to relatives where people at
the two locations that he went shooting
at he heard in his head people talking
about him so I think you get somebody
here you're starting to see an image of
somebody who's increasingly isolated
somebody who's hearing things that
nobody else is hearing he's got an edge
against the world this doesn't strike me
as somebody that's very sophisticated
that's going to stuck going all over the
country you know they'd be tracking his
credit cards obviously if his phone goes
on they're going to hit that I think
he's likely in the woods places that
he's familiar with and that turns this
thing almost into a military
operation well uh he might have a police
scanner we'll learn about uh this is the
night and let's hope it's quick uh the
time goes on Chris and Paul thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else